ich habe mich aufgeregt eigentlich das
zugegeben es sollte sinnvolle ausweisung
ökologische sanierung der häuser was ist
die baupreise sind massiv hochgegangen
ganze wochenende ist schon aufgeregt
von neuen gebieten werden damit viel
über klara geywitz das ist unsere
mit dämmung ja ja klar ja so und wenn
und deswegen geht man eher auf kleinere
mehr menschen sich diesen traum vom
grundstücke aber ich finde schon dass
bauministerin übrigens auch von spd die
eigenheim auch wirklich wahr machen
die ministerin hier im grunde genommen
man das nicht versteht damals nicht
den gesamten ländlichen raum mit ihrer
können so wie es in anderen ländern eben
verstanden hat das ist doch eigentlich
hat den wunsch der deutschen nach einem
der fall ist denn die eigentumsquote in
bevölkerung diskreditiert damals
ein ding was dem habe ich nicht so fern
eigenheim kritisiert in einem gespräch
tatsächlich in meinem freundes und
deutschland ist immer noch im
gelegen hat die motive für diese
europäischen vergleich rekord mäßig
bekanntenkreis so ist da ist der traum
mit der taz als sie gesagt eigenheime
investitionen zu verstehen und heute
dann auch das eigenheim zu haben was mir
niedrig also weniger verbote mehr
sind im grunde ökonomisch und ökologisch
überhaupt eine andere ministerin das
noch wichtig werden neben zuschüssen
unsinnig sagte bundesbau ministerin sagt
möglichkeiten das will ich gerne von
bauen von einfamilienhäusern in frage
heute war es ein bisschen lotterie also
stellt dann naja dann legen die axt an
die die am anfang da waren die haben was
einer engagierten bundesbauministerium
wörtlich es ist ökonomisch und
bekommen danach die nicht mehr
eigentlich auch ihre wer mir noch
ökologisch unsinnig
höhe
die wurzel einer tragenden branche für
wenn jede generation
wichtig dass der staat ein bisschen
unsere wirtschaft da hängen so viele
zurück steckt also bei diesen hohen
einfamilienhäuser bauen wenn dann die
mittelständler dran handwerker die im
heran da ich finde das sehr spannend was
preisen kassiert der staat ja immer dann
menschen auf 150 quadratmeter zu beginn
sie gesagt haben es klingt fast liberal
hausbau und im wohnungsbau tätig sind
mit ab wenn er beispielsweise
konservativ für mich und nicht nach spd
grunderwerbsteuer einnimmt ich wäre sehr
zu fünft leben und dann nach einer zeit
architektenbüros und so weiter das wird
dafür wenn wir damals im
immer älter und
gehen die kinder aus dem haus das haus
gesellschaftlichen kraftakt machen und
die haben wir haben wir dann das leder
mal eben so in einem interview erklärt
sagen bei der ersten immobilie keine
schrumpft und in dem moment aber nicht
weil man der meinung ist dass das die
grunderwerbsteuer ja wenn ich es richtig
jeder so leben können wie er das klingt
so zitat ende sagt sie gegenüber der taz
leute sollen anders leben und wenn mir
sehe kaum frau gallwitz aus potsdam ist
für mich eher nach der fdp aber sie
leute kommen die mir erklären wie ich
das haus schrumpft nicht das ist zwar
haben auch er ich bin ja nicht hier eine
das richtig wie kann man in brandenburg
leben sollte werde ich sowieso sauer
weil ich entscheide selber gerne wie ich
partei sichtlich hier ich bin anders als
tatsächlich dafür schrumpft offenbar die
wie in einer großstadt wie berlin berlin
lebe das wird auch so bleiben das werden
bei ihnen aber
bereitschaft menschen so leben zu lassen
dann gleich ist hierfür die welt
oder sehen etwas erwerben zu lassen was
auch die menschen so durchsetzen ja
mitte eine solche meinung vertreten ist
angenommen jeder so leben wie er will
mir rätselhaft und ich glaube sie wird
völlig zurecht und und und wir wollen ja
sie wollen eben ein eigenheim sich den
sich in brandenburg damit auch nicht
ist der ursprung des kommunismus so aber
besonders beliebt machen ja ich frage
nicht drangsaliert werden in einem in
traum vom eigenheim erfüllen zu können
mich das auch warum hat sie das gemacht
genau daran hat mich erinnert
einem öko und ökologischen
stattdessen hören wird nur boote dass
ich glaube dass ich glaube tatsächlich
daran dass ich bin natürlich ganz bei
dass so ein bisschen lauterbach syndrom
irgendwas nicht sein da weil es nicht
korsett nur leben dürfen das so weit
ihnen inhaltlich glaube sie haben völlig
ist sie haben jetzt die ganze zeit nicht
ökologisch richtig ist oder ökonomisch
recht so eine art platz pro person per
vor die 400.000 wohnungen die sie sich
geht dass uns die form der häuser die
vernünftig oder unsinnig sogar
vorgenommen haben im koalitionsvertrag
se pauschal festzulegen die es in
kriegt sie im leben nach hin in diesem
wir anstreben hat sich auch madig
tatsächlich ist aber der eigenheim
deutschland gibt soviel platz kann eine
jahr aber sie wollte jetzt irgendwie
person haben und mehr nicht das klingt
wunsch der hier diskreditiert wird ein
gemacht wird denn ich bleib dabei dieser
glaube ich nochmal vorkommen und mit ein
für mich nach nordkorea oder nach
wunsch von vielen tausend bin ich gar
bisschen eigenheim bashing läuft man
traum vom eigenheim so schwerer ist
sowjetunion ist natürlich völliger
quatsch und meine antwort auf ihre these
eigentlich dann auch immer mit ihr aber
millionen von menschen werden in der
bleibt ein traum für viele viele
korona pandemie gesehen der wunsch nach
die spd ist doch die partei der normalen
ist auch ganz emotional denn während
menschen und ich möchte mir nicht sagen
leute in dem sinne in ihrem
einem eigenen kleinen häuschen mit
corona konnten meine brüder und meine
selbstverständnis und lange nicht ja
lassen von welchem verantwortlichen
offensichtlich haben sie sich von denen
garten irgendwo ist vielleicht nicht das
ganze familie die wir alle hier in
ganz schön entfernt weil wenn ein paar
politiker oder von welcher
berlin oder in anderen städten in ganz
was sie in berlin-mitte vorrang hat aber
verantwortlichen politikerinnen auch
kleinen wohnungen wohnen alle nur an
mehr kollegen ihre bürgersprechstunde
in ländlichen gebieten rheinland pfalz
immer wie ich mein leben dann zu
einen ort immer gehen und das war das
ordentlich machen würden dann würden sie
haus meiner großeltern das ist groß
in nordrhein-westfalen in hoyerswerda in
hören dass die leute durch die union die
gestalten du hast völlig recht und in
obwohl sie dann noch zu zehnt und das
berchtesgaden in cloppenburg und vechta
wahl gewonnen muss ich hier leider doch
wäre nicht gegangen insofern stimmt mich
dieser gesellschaft ist es ja auch in
sonst wo überhaupt und dieser traum vom
der pandemie deutlich und die kinder
mal sagen aber und ich wollte diese
jedenfalls es ist übrigens das zweite
denkt niemand und ist es natürlich ein
aussage
mal schon dass diese regierung oder aus
eigenheim ist aber in den letzten jahren
also ich sag mal so das lag jetzt nicht
wichtiges motiv von menschen ein
dieser regierung mit dem bauen gespielt
viel schwerer geworden zu realisieren
unbedingt daran weil wir jetzt so stark
einfamilienhaus zu bauen oder ein
wird leichtfertig aus kurzsichtigen
niedrige zinsen hin oder her weil dies
gewesen wären sondern ich glaube er dass
reihenhäuschen zu nehmen wegen kindern
erwägungen der erste war herr habeck der
die spd trotz der schlecht der eigenen
weil kinder sich dort im kleinen garten
noch immens teuer geworden ist und die
bewegen können oder auch mal auf der
jetzigen ökonom geschnittene
schlechteren performen waren oder eine
straße spielen können während in einer
die die kfw mittel für ökologisches
ökologischen anforderungen machen es
abwehr war dass die spd es geschafft ist
wohnung in einer großstadt kinder
nochmal teurer es müssen der heizung
schlecht aufgehoben sind das ist ein
bauen über nacht gefährlichen hat da ist
doch wie so schlecht waren als union
wesentliches motiv für den bau von
ausgetauscht werden wärmepumpen
also das ist doch mittlerweile
fast die ganze branche zusammengebrochen
allgemeingut oder nicht also wir haben
eigenen häuser und es kommt dazu dass
integriert werden die dämmungen neu
niemand wusste was davon niemand ist
die eigenen häuser ja viel kleiner was
einfach keinen guten wahlkampf geführt
gemacht wird alles wird teurer und dann
konsultiert worden das ist jetzt wieder
wir hatten den spitzenkandidaten der
die grundstücksflächen angeht geworden
offensichtlich von den bürgerinnen
ein bisschen hergerichtet worden eine
wird uns auch noch mit diesem argument
bürgern nicht gewollt war und dann kommt
sind also 1000 quadratmeter wie einst
milliarde gibt es wieder gab es wieder
das eigenheim madig gemacht schon im
zeit in der demokratie auch mal zum
oder sowas ist doch kein mensch mehr
die waren sofort vergriffen heute nach
wechsel was er grundsätzlich nicht
schlecht ist wird mir trotzdem derzeit
letzten wahlkampf hat übrigens toni
selbst ihnen etwas wohlhabenderen
paar stunden waren sie treffen weil es
hofreiter von den grünen den bau von
gerne lieber eine unionsgeführte
viel zu wenig ist und das sind alles
gegenden sondern es werden kleinere
bundesregierung wünschen
eigenheimen scharf kritisiert und jetzt
grundstücksparzellen mit einem kleinen
leute die was bauen wollen und zwar ein
stößt die bundesbauministerium ins
haus bauen wollen oder ihre wohnung
garten oder so aber trotzdem bleibt
gleiche verbot sein ich finde statt
modernisierung was immer und es ist
dieser traum bestehen weil sie im
übrigen auch so ist dass sie sich das
verbote sollte es finanzielle anreiz
einfach zu wenig diese regierung hat die
heute als junge familie fast gar nicht
das wirst du damit ging es eine
mehr leisten trotz niedrigen zinsen aber